welcome to getting started with artifact
registry
in this video series i'm going to walk
you through setting up some common use
cases for artifact registry
but before i get into how to get started
it probably makes sense to tell you what
artifact registry is
artifact registry manages your container
images and language packages while
integrating with cloud's build
test and deploy suite and third-party ci
cd systems
if you're familiar with container
registry you're thinking artifact
registry sure sounds similar
and you're right artifact registry is
the next generation of container
registry
container registry has provided a single
place for your team to manage docker
images
perform vulnerability analysis and
decide who can access what with
fine-grained access control
existing ci cd integrations let you set
up fully automated docker pipelines to
get fast feedback
in an effort to build upon this powerful
foundation
google cloud created artifact registry
artifact registry offers even more
fine-grained permissions allowing you to
control access at the project
or registry level you can create
multiple regional repositories within a
single google cloud project
you can create multiple repos under a
project with independent registry
specific permissions
so you have control over where artifacts
are stored and who can access them
after hearing about artifact registry i
bet you can't wait to get started
let's walk through the steps using a
hypothetical company i've created
drain drain is autonomous
artificially intelligent voice-enabled
plumbing for the modern home
i'll make drain part of your pipeline
using artifact registry in the software
pipeline
now if you don't think that's like a
little bit funny this is going to be a
long video series for you
you can create a new repository list
existing repositories
and configure access controls through
the gcp console
or through the gcloud command line tool
today
i'm using gcloud to find out about
setting up the gcloud cli
check out the guide link below alright
let's get started
first you'll need a google cloud project
with billing enabled
you can use an existing project or
create a new one
next enable the artifact registry api in
the console
then open a new terminal window
to create a new repository type your
gcloud command
in this format where repository
is the name of your new repository
format is the repository format which is
either
docker maven or npm location is the
regional
or multi-regional location for the
repository and you can leave this out if
you set a default location
and description is an optional
description of the repository
including the async flag causes the
command to return immediately
without waiting for the operation in
progress to complete
so for example here's a command from my
drain app
my repository is called drain pipe it's
a docker container
location i've chosen is ufcentral1 and
i've included this description so i can
easily track the contents of my
repositories
and here is the result to view a list of
repositories you'll want to run
this command where project is the
project id
if you don't include this flag then the
current or default project is used
use the location flag to view
repositories from a specific location
you can also use location all to list
repositories across all locations
if you leave out the location flag the
command uses the default location if a
default is configured
and if there isn't a default location
leaving out this flag
list repositories across all locations
so
when i run the command without a project
or location i'm shown
my current project here as you can see
creating and viewing your repositories
is super simple
but before you dive headlong into
artifact registry
you have one very important
consideration security
if you currently use any gcp products
you're probably at least somewhat
familiar with the roles associated with
access controls
the most basic roles are owner editor
and viewer
and although you can use these primitive
project wide owner editor and viewer
roles to grant access to repositories
using specific artifact registry roles
enables you to apply the security
principle of least privilege
so that users and service accounts only
have access to the permissions that are
required
for example the artifact registry dot
reader role
allows a user to view and get artifacts
just from a specific project's
repositories
whereas the roles reader role allows the
user to
view and get any existing resources and
data from
all cloud components of the project to
grant a permission for a user
naturally you grant a role that includes
that permission
where appropriate you should use the
artifact registry roles to control
access to your repositories
rather than those project-wide roles you
can grant
these artifact registry roles reader
writer
repository administrator and
administrator let's grant some roles for
the repository we just made for my
completely fake company
drain again i'm using the gcloud cli
because it rocks
to add roles via the cli i need to
create a reference policy file named
policy.yaml
in that file i start with the bindings
key then i name a role
and list members here's a more complete
reference policy example
notice i have an owner for the whole
project and then artifact registry
specific roles
for reader you can see there is a
service account with read privileges
and a specific user with read privileges
you can find a complete reference
template in the documentation which
contains
more example user and service account
names to add a team member to a project
and grant them an artifact registry role
i add them to the policy file then
from the command line i run this command
passing the name of the project and the
path to my emo file
to get the currently configured policy i
run gcloud projects
get in policy passing the name of the
project
and there you have it you're ready to
create a new repository
list existing repositories and configure
access controls for artifact registry
but there's so much more to know about
artifact registry stay
tuned for future episodes of getting
started with artifact registry and
to see a guide on these tasks and so
much more check out the documentation
i'll see you next time
[Music]
you